the jurogan experience and that was it
that's the same attack on floyd he was
attacking todd
and
so i was taught i think i knocked him
down
in like the last round like he got him
and
it was i think the scorecard was too
late or something i don't know but how
old is he now victor's got to be like 37
38 years old now right
if i'm guessing
35.
man so when that floyd fight happened he
had to be in his early days he got him
there you go i got it let me see that
again
oh yeah come on hit him with it bow
that left [ __ ] the right hand behind
you got it oh he dropped him yeah
[ __ ]
i got it there
35.
he's like yeah you got me
you know what's crazy crazy is that
floyd is still doing these exhibitions
making millions oh did you see the the
one he just did yeah he looked fantastic
i'm sorry he's like i ain't got a
haircut for this [ __ ] yeah scraggly
i think he's enjoying that look going
out whooping people ass like yo for
millions of dollars i ain't got to
promote this [ __ ] i'm just showing up
hanging out ass woman's like
it's like floyd wait to get hit
to see where you at with your power i'm
like okay now i'm gonna [ __ ] demolish
you he was holding the ring card girl's
card and walking around
did you see what he was doing oh [ __ ] he
held up the card in between rounds he
walked floyd walked around with the card
he put on a show because he's like he's
it's really smart because he's giving
them his the money's worth it's not just
a boxing exhibition he's putting on a
show he's laughing and dancing he's got
a big smile on his face while the
fight's going on
incredible and that was a guy who he has
barred before would you fight no
no
i'm too banged up i am too old
i'm not interested anymore
muscle memory alone you'll probably take
somebody out just just mere muscle
memory
i'm not
yeah i mean probably i could [ __ ] some
people up i'm not interested it's a man
it's an old man in our gym
main street
he
he looks like a problem like
just from
he's so rugged and so hard
that
i would never even play with him like
just go up and put your hands up just
for muscle memory alone he'll [ __ ]
destroy you
just like
like he just does it so much like the
[ __ ] is the problem some guys can keep
it up they can like floyd 45 years old
looks [ __ ] amazing the best example
is tyson
55 years old and they're still talking
about him fighting either logan or jake
paul
like that is crazy
and i don't know what would happen
oh man
if logan paul
would beat tyson i would [ __ ] just i
would i think
jake would probably be the better fight
jake whatever the heavier the better one
is jake jake is the one who knocks
people out logan logan's more of a boxer
i would [ __ ] just die i can't believe
that would happen i would just i'm like
because floyd when when he fought floyd
i think floyd was really
when floyd got tired of the [ __ ] he
just popped yeah he put it on him he put
it in he's so big and i think that he i
think that one punches
kind of just wobbled the [ __ ] out of him
and floyd was holding him up like yo
don't [ __ ] up your money
listen god damn it hold up
it's the parts in that fight where floyd
was like yo let me show you i don't give
a [ __ ] how big you are you not on this
level oh he's definitely not on that
level but i think he was too big and he
i'm telling you it's it's a part in that
fight where floyd snapped his neck back
and i was like oh [ __ ] he gone and floyd
was like you could see floyd holding him
up like don't fall
i noticed floyd was definitely out
boxing the [ __ ] out of it but the
difference between
floyd and mike tyson is floyd's 155
pounds
mike tyson's 220 solid as a rock even if
he's 55 he's on all the mexican
supplements he's on everything they got
they use electrical muscular stimulation
on him you know what they do you ever
seen those things they do to build you
up he does exercises where they put
these he talked about it on the podcast
where they do these uh these pads
connected to wires yeah and so he's
doing these exercises and these things
are like charging his muscles and it
makes your muscles develop faster and
better oh [ __ ] yeah so when he got back
into shape yeah